because you mentioned the magic when you
look out there
perhaps it's not a scientific question
but
you don't have to be scientific all the
time yeah well this you said magic so
there's a there's a magic to Magic that
is in part scientific and in part
I don't know whatever whatever fills us
with uh as humans when we look up at the
stars do you think
the universe is full of life or not like
you know when you're sitting drinking
some wine looking up at the stars and
and wandering as a human uh do you think
we're alone or do you think
it's life is everywhere I am going to
make such an unmagical response to that
my response is that's the scientific
response yeah that if we are alone
then the universe is a statistical
absurdity
yeah and and I have no doubt in my mind
and that is an unscientific response as
well but I have no doubt in my mind that
the universe is steaming with life what
if
it keeps dying
this is what life does
but unfortunately so so the
so me that Extinction is as a process as
a part of the process of Life Extinction
seems to be a fundamental both negative
and positive component
so what if all the complex life out
there just keeps dying and not making
way for like we're actually uh
statistical anomaly in uh us being able
to survive that l in the Drake equation
being able to survive long enough to
form complex organisms of the kind like
mammals are things with brains things
Ellie's not about that L is about how
long a civilization is capable of being
detectable which means that rich
Technologies and you know being
detectable okay so there's a more
nuanced things to help because you can
have intelligent civilizations that are
not very detectable yeah we had
civilization
for thousands of years uh we started to
be detectable 150 years ago
so it's about technology technology that
we can actually capture from from space
you become visible to your neighbors
uh and and this is all about the Fermi
Paradox right it takes time obviously if
we're taking again ourselves as a model
but this is the only one we have
um to get to the point where we become
detectable
but look at the edge of the universe
even if Life as we understand it not not
saying even as we know it but as we can
understand it started 10 billion years
ago and it takes four billion years to
get to uh the point where it becomes
detectable that means that the first
planet where those civilizations started
off starting to be depictable when we
were still cyanobacteria in ponds so
they were you know throwing messages and
that were passing above our heads at
that point and those civilization when
you look at them now close to 10 billion
years after the start so their son would
be dead okay in the best case scenario
they move somewhere else and what that
means is that Civilization are going to
rise die or move and transform
themselves we can see ourselves changing
we know that humans are still changing
as a species the human being in in a
thousand or even 500 years from now
might not be looking a lot like we are
doing uh right now who knows where where
we will be will might be migrating into
our planetary system we might be
migrating somewhere else well you said
migrating but it seems when you look at
life it doesn't necessarily migrate it
it expands so it's not
or place a or or place B is place a and
plays B it seems to be it could be we
are talking about the human civilization
here uh so there are different Factor if
you are a cyanobacteria or any type of
even a mammal that doesn't have the
technology to escape
the planet we were born on then it's
plan a it is right there you know
whatever happens to your planet you are
tied to it you cannot Escape it uh for a
human it's a little different yeah it's
a and b uh or whatever you know we can
so we have to expect that a number of
the civilization
extraterrestrial civilization that might
be technologically advanced a number of
them will have disappeared just because
they run the course of their evolution
or because their son run out of fuel and
they didn't have a way to escape or they
were wiped out by any kind of event and
then they will there will be those that
survive